from wildly unconventional sci-fi
creepers to twist details of demonic
possession we've got a little something
to unnerve even the savviest of Shaka
touring cinephiles these are the most
disturbing movies in the past decade if
you've entered the earth-shattering
rabbit hole of Jonathan Glazers music
videos you already know the director has
a particular penchant for pushing
boundaries with unsettling imagery and
ominous tones one might even say Glaser
rebels in the bewildering as few
directors dare it's only natural then
that he'd continue weaving challenging
images and disturbing themes into a
speech or films few would argue that
Glaser hasn't already tested some
serious boundaries with mm searing crime
drama sexy beast and 2004 psychosexual
mist rebirth but neither of these films
could even begin to prepare us for our
Glaser would push things with 2013's
under the skin it's a full-on assault of
the senses from its opening moments to
its last it features a relevant Tori
performance from Scarlett Johansson
that's about as far from the MCU as you
can get and there's a scene about
halfway through that so relentlessly
unnerving you'll struggle not to turn it
off
keep watching though because even if
under the skin often feels like a movie
you survive more than watch crossing the
finish line on this extraterrestrial
Odyssey is one of the most rewarding
cinematic experiences you'd ever hope to
endure Argentinian filmmaker Gaspar
Inouye has made quite a reputation for
himself over the years more than just
about any other director with a film on
this list Noah has made it his personal
quest to shock and provoke he broke
minds and pushed viewers to the limits
with a hyper violent emotionally
punishing reverse narrative of 2002's
irreversible but it seems he had a
different sort of head trip in mind for
his third offering 2009 to Lucinda
Tory's pseudo afterlife drama and to the
boy no way opens the action with a
drug-dealing french expats with a
penchant for wild hallucinogens meeting
his end in a Tokyo bar upon death his
soul is cast free of his body and
meanders through the film with an
unknown goal in mind no way captures
said souls every meandering post like
moments and an incredible point of view
shots his camera floating in and out of
moments memories and molecules like an
omnipotent Spectre and yes that boldly
stylistic approaches as breathtakingly
brilliant and immersive as it is dogged
ly disconcerting the result is a film
that says oddly calming and
thought-provoking as it is vividly
adversarial not to mention his mind
bogging the original as any film
produced in the past decade when the
director of one of the greatest horror
movies in
cinematic history claims your film is
the scariest movie they've ever seen
you know you've done something special
so in the legendary William Friedkin the
man behind the Exorcist started telling
people that Jennifer Kent's 2014 indie
movie the babadook will quote scare the
hell out of you genre lovers immediately
took notice Friedkin wasn't lying
possessed of a singular sense of eerie
the babadook tells the story of a single
mother struggling to raise a son with
some serious emotional issues of course
given that the woman's husband died
enroute to the child's birth it's clear
that both mother and son have some
deep-rooted issues to work through those
issues complicate their lives even
further when a horrifying children's
book called mr. babadook appears in
their home as Kent slowly begins to
unwind her unholy creep past the
surprising narrative begins to take
shape one that insightful early
explorers heavy emotional themes about
surviving trauma and the struggles of
being a single parent with a devastating
case of depression as it happens the
babadook is also a first-rate monster
movie with more genuine scares than your
average Jon R affair yes the babadook
will scare the hell out of you but it'll
leave your heart in your throat -
according to writer director Ari Astor
his brutalist 2018 shocker hereditary is
really just a little family drama at its
core but that's sort of like calling
jaws a charming tale of a fish out of
water so while we can't say that
hereditary isn't a family drama we also
want to be crystal clear that hereditary
is definitely more than just that still
true to ask their statements hereditary
initially presents itself as an atypical
sort of indie drama about a family in
grief as the film unfolds a deep dark
past begins to rise to the surface and
hereditary spirals into a pulse-pounding
supernatural nightmare that you have to
see to believe just be warned that
you'll never be able to unsee it in case
you haven't experienced it for yourself
will simply say you'll know the precise
moment when Astor flips the proverbial
switch from family drama to full-blown
family tragedy you'll know because the
moment it happens is easily one of the
most shocking in the history of cinema
it's a brutal exhausting affair but if
you manage to stick with it you'll bear
witness not that just one of the
greatest horror movies of the decade but
of all time with asters hereditary
immediately raising the bar for genre
filmmakers young and old it seemed
unlikely that anyone would top the film
in terms of unadulterated head rolling
shock value for the foreseeable future
seems the only person came
of even coming close was asked to
himself while midsummer may not quite
match hereditary in terms of shocks and
scares it might be the better film in
terms of emotional impact and
mercilessly ominous energy of course as
they're told by said midsummer is a
relatively straightforward breakup movie
believe us when we say that midsummer is
a breakup movie in the same way that
hereditary is a family drama which means
that it's not really a breakup movie at
all
no no no please please please I'm not
I'm not trying to attack you it feels
like you are well then well then I'm
sorry I'm so I just got confused the
relationship in question belongs to
Danny played by Florence pew man
Christian played by Jack Renner and if
there ever was a couple in need of a
breakup it's damn but nothing is ever
that easy in the worlds of aster and
from the torturous opening moments of
midsummer the director is out to turn
the screws of the pair's doomed
relationship and increasingly twisted
ways by the time the couple on their
pals get to the titular swedish festival
fates are effectively sealed though
nothing can even remotely prepare you
for the gory sun-drenched mayhem aster
has in store for the rest of the film
like several of the filmmakers with
quite fulfill its on this list lars von
trier has developed a bit of a
reputation for making shamelessly
confrontational films that tend to be
difficult to watch over the years von
trier and his movies have been labeled
many things by fans and detractors alike
his 2011 sci-fi drama melancholia finds
a director at his most nihilistic and
also at a stylistic height the film
follows a pair of sisters played by
Kirsten Dunst than Charlotte
Gainsborough each struggles to keep
their lives together as mankind has
recently been made aware that a big blue
planet is on a collision course with
earth and the world will soon cease to
exist melancholia opens with one of the
saddest weddings ever committed to film
it ends with the earth literally being
obliterated the moments in between offer
glimpses of lovingly crafted moments of
pre doom bliss and equally dour
explorations of the sisters lives once
they learned the end is nigh somewhere
in the mix von Trier delivers a lavishly
photographed and emotionally draining
apocalyptic drama that's as hard to
watch as it is to look away from prior
to helming 2016's Doctor Strange scott
derrickson made a name for himself among
genre enthusiasts he caught our
attention with 2005's possession drama
The Exorcism of Emily Rose but it was
2012 sinister that proved Dericks in a
horror purist of the first order the
film follows the story of
washed-up true-crime author played by
the fantastic ethan hawke he moves his
family into a house where a grisly crime
has taken place so he can research the
events up close and personal
unfortunately when he finds an old box
of super 8 films in his attic the man
and his family get a little closer to
the truth than anyone would have wanted
be warned that those 8 millimeter films
are likely to cost you a few nights of
sleep but there are only a small part of
what makes sinister such a black-hearted
delight the film is at its best when
wallowing and ominous tones and gritty
gothic imagery and derrickson makes the
most of Sinister's menacing aura he
takes a perverse pleasure in the film's
slow burn approach and pulls the
blood-stained rug out from viewers and a
finale that'll have you peeking through
your sweaty palms it can often be quite
difficult to decipher exactly what it is
about a movie that gets under your skin
in the case of Julia Dick or Neos
astonishing first feature raw it's a
little easier to figure out because the
core neo essentially spends the entirety
of the film's 100 minute runtime
unleashing a near-constant deluge of
horrifying sounds and images and
scenarios that's not to say raw is a
mile a minute shocked for the shake of
shock gorefest
quite the opposite in fact the core neo
takes a decidedly steady handed approach
to her film the only now shocks as they
come she does it all while quietly
delivering a vicious unapologetically
sexy college drama that legitimately
turns to genre on its head
we should tell you up front that the
film follows the trials of a young
university student who unexpectedly
finds herself with an insatiable
appetite for human flesh but instead of
reveling in gory effects in schlocky
scares dick or neo takes a humanistic
approach the raw shocking story
she uses the gore to bolster a witty
insightful character study that becomes
against all obvious odds a compelling
coming-of-age drama about cannibalism
we're not going to bore you by trying to
explain what shane carruth upstream
color is about if only because entire
thesis papers could be written on that
particularly slippery subject we'd offer
that upstream color is a film less
concerned with what it's about than what
it can make you feel and there's
seemingly no end to what Carruth can
achieve on that particular front we'll
simply say that the film follows a woman
who after being parasitically hypnotized
by a thief and having her entire life
looted is left with a ruined future and
no memory of what happened she meets a
man with a similar story played by Carew
and as they beautifully try to piece
together their individual miseries they
stumble upon a truth beyond imagination
what follows is nothing short of a
deeply paranoid cinematic assault on the
that simply has to be experienced to be
believed upstream color is a decidedly
unnerving experience that will have you
scratching your head for days months and
even years after the credits roll set in
an isolated mountainous region of Europe
circa the 15th century
Lucas Fargo Feld's gothic nightmare
haggis Sousa propels itself forward at a
sub glacial clip while the film succeeds
at capturing the slow pace of life in
the Hills Fargo Feld also uses that P
scene to cast the hypnotic sort of spell
over viewers now I won't be broken until
the film stomach-churning final moments
all route to that beyond brutal finale
Fargo Field uncorks a pitch-black folk
tale about a single woman with the pagan
past trying to survive the wilderness
and raise her infant daughter in
relative peace of course when your
neighbors live in constant fear of magic
and spirits in witchcraft the natural
world is far from your most dangerous
foe while it's certain to test the
patience of those seeking to sate their
bloodlust and schlocky scares haggis
oozes final act is certain to haunt the
minds of any viewers who make it to the
end for years to come if history has
taught us anything it's that Hollywood
loves a good story of rebellious smart
whip youths running amuck what classics
like rebel without a cause a Clockwork
Orange and spring breakers have kept the
bar for such films raised perpetually
high over the years Tory Finley's
thoroughbreds proves that there's still
room for one of cinema's favorite
subgenres to grow at the center of
Finley's dark trauma tea is a pair of
upper-crust Connecticut teens who exist
on opposing ends of the emotional
spectrum Lily played by Anna Taylor joy
feels everything too strongly while
olivia cooks Amanda is incapable of
feeling anything like you don't have any
negative feeling like I don't have any
feelings ever when the estranged friends
are reunited they find that they're each
losing control of their lives and are
uniquely equipped to help each other out
that help comes at a cost as the girls
one shot at liberation involves a
deviously violent plan while it propels
thoroughbreds narrative forward it's
hardly the focal point of the film with
Finley instead using it to craft a
penetrating character study about a pair
of brilliant but tragically fractured
young minds horror movies are
essentially designed to take audiences
into the dark corners of the world and
show them the unspeakable things that
happen there sometimes that dark corner
is a physical place as in the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre other times it's a
place in the mind like the cell
Nickolas patches grisly debut the eyes
of my mother is the rare case where mind
in place converged to explore one of the
darkest corners ever
captured on film the film's opening
moments are surprisingly serene with a
girl in her family living in relative
peace on an isolated farm but pêche
takes a sledgehammer to that idealic
life early in the action when he does
the eyes of my mother goes dark in ways
that words simply cannot convey ways
that ensure the film will stay burned
into your brain for all eternity
we'd wager you've heard whispers of the
film's vivid depictions of violence
torture and dwara while the film shot in
stunning black and whites is unflinching
in its depiction of set jacks the most
gruesome deeds tend to occur off screen
oh that only heightens viewers reactions
besh further deepens the darkness by
using the fragile emotional astark iike
Maggie lays against viewers and service
of turning the eyes of my mother into a
character study about trauma and soul
consuming loneliness
speaking of soul-crushing loneliness
it's the main culprit at work in the
relentlessly bleak possession film the
black coats daughter directed by oz
Perkins the son of psychos Anthony that
being said there is a mysterious evil
force running amok in the film that may
or may not have claimed the soul of the
central character and forced her into
committing unconscious acts of violence
possible demons and possessions aside
loneliness and isolation are the real
driving forces at play in the black
coats daughter the film unfolds largely
on the grounds of an all-girls Catholic
school somewhere in the far distant
north when two of the girls played by
Karen and chip guy and Lucy Boynton are
stranded there over winter break things
get weird very quickly with the younger
girl apparently being possessed by some
unseen demonic presence meanwhile a
parallel narrative finds a grieving
couple picking up a desperate young
woman played by Emma Roberts at a bus
stop
not knowing she's an escaped mental
patient these narratives will eventually
converge in wickedly clever fashion and
to utterly heartbreaking effect Perkins
controls the action every step of the
way with a steady hand and singular
vision building a suffocating sense of
atmospheric thread into every frame at
the pill in doing so he delivers a
deeply humanist supernatural tragedy and
one of the darkest possession films
we've ever seen it's probably a bit
unfair to label Darren Aronofsky's
mother a horror film although there's a
palpable sense of unease running through
the film and patently horrific moments
throughout if we're being completely
honest mother doesn't fit neatly into
any single genre because there's never
really been a movie quite like it before
and we're still not sure how Aronofsky
got such a brazenly over-the-top
freakshow made we're glad he did though
because Aronofsky's frenzied tale of a
couple
Dilek existence being demolished by
increasingly bizarre occurrences from
the outside world is about as much DB
escanso fun as you can have in a panic
inducing movie even if we've come to
accept a certain level of button-pushing
from Aronofsky over the years mother
finds the director pushing boundaries
further than ever
in doing so he crafted a harrowing
cinematic allegory unlike any film
that's come before and likely anything
that will come after sometimes it's not
so much the story of film tells that
makes one uneasy as it's the characters
who populate it if you've already seen
Dan Gilroy searing new cycle satire
Nightcrawler you know full well that
Luke bloom is one of those characters
you also know that the reason the
character in the film itself is so
unsettling is because of the abrasive
energy Jake Gyllenhaal brings to the
role though Gyllenhaal's work in
Nightcrawler was ignored by the Academy
his turn as the morally empty bloom
remains not just one of the best
performances of that year but of his
career Nightcrawler may well be the best
film the actor has ever started and
undoubtedly the most disturbing the film
unfolds among the seedy underbelly of
Los Angeles and vines Jill and Paul's
bloom attempting to make a name for
himself in the world of freelance crime
journalism as he rises to fame bloom
begins to eradicate the line between
eyewitness to tragedy and willing
participant bolstered by crackling
writing and direction from Gilroy
Gyllenhaal's performances bloom
transforms Nightcrawler from satire into
a full-blown creep show about a modern
vampire with a troubling taste for
on-camera blood when I say that I want
these things I mean that I want them and
I don't want to have to ask again with
boldly stylistic flicks like pusher
drive and only God forgives Danish
filmmaker Nicolas Winding Ruffin has
proved himself to be a filmmaker wholly
obsessed with seedy pulp dramas dressed
up in stark neon drenched visuals though
it remains a divisive film even among
reference fanbase the neon demon is
essentially the culmination of
everything that's made repin such an
intriguing artistic force oddly enough
the neon demon also features one of
repens least compelling setups a pretty
young woman moves to LA in the hopes of
becoming a model the wickedness repens
spins from that simplistic setup is
nothing short of genre genius with the
city and everyone who runs it literally
feasted on the woman's youthful vitality
even as they wax poetic on what beauty
really is visually arresting a morally
fanciful and often gruesomely realistic
the neon demon is basically everything
Nicolas Winding reppin does
well turned up to 11 love it or hate it
the film remains one of the most deeply
jarring portraits of fashion culture the
movies have ever presented structured as
a near kaleidoscopic look at tragedies
past and present Len Ramsey's we need to
talk about kevin is a film less
concerned with the motivations of the
fateful act at its core a mass killing
in a school than it is with the lives
behind it as such the film focuses much
of its narrative energy on a mother
played by Tilda Swinton and her son
Kevin who will one day be the architect
of the unthinkable tragedy the film
follows the pair's troubled relationship
from birth and finds Swinton giving one
of the finest performances of her career
as a mother who desperately tries to
love her son even as his psychopathic
behaviors become more pronounced with
age
it's a perilous landscape with Ramsey
deftly walking the tightrope between
humanizing and demonizing Kevin even as
the film explores the tragic mother who
always saw the evil within
as the film jumps back and forth in time
exploring the aftermath of the violence
as much as the prelude a soul-shaking
sense of dread takes whole and we need
to talk about kevin becomes a fractured
mirror designed to reflect a sickness
consuming the world around us wisely
ramsay offers no remedy and instead
leaves us to wallow in the mess we as a
society seemed destined to keep cleaning
up check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one